How about
so we should first decide what we're
talking about.
We're not talking about my views of
political correctness despite what you
might have inferred from the last
speaker's comments.
This is how it looks to me.
We essentially need something
approximating a low resolution grant
narrative to unitus and we did narrative
to united because otherwise we don't
have peace.
What's playing out in the universities
and in broader society right now is a
debate between two fundamental low
resolution narratives.
Neither of which can be completely
accurate because they can't encompass
all the details.
Obviously human beings have an
individual element and a collective
element.
A group element.
Let's say the question is what story
should be paramount,
and this is how it looks to me in the
West.
We have reasonably functional,
reasonably free,
remarkably productive,
stable hierarchies that are open to
consideration of the dispossessed that
hierarchies generally create.
Our societies are freer and functioning
more effectively than any societies or
anywhere else in the world and that and
then any societies ever have and as far
as I'm concerned,
and I think there's good reason to
assume this,
it's because the fundamental low
resolution,
a grant narrative that we've oriented
ourselves around in the West is one of
the sovereignty of the individual and
it's predicated on the idea that all
things considered the best way for me to
interact with someone else's individual
to individual and to react to that
person as if they're both part of the
process because that's the right way of
thinking about it.
The psychological process by which
things we don't understand can yet be
explored and buy.
Things that aren't properly organized in
our society can be yet set right.
The reason we're valuable as
individuals,
both with regards to our rights and
responsibilities,
is because that's our essential purpose.
Announce our nobility and that's our
function.
What's happening as far as I'm concerned
in the universities in particular and
spreading very rapidly out into the
broader world,
including the corporate world,
much to.
It's a much to what should be its
chagrin is a collectivist narrative and
of course there's some utility in a
collectivist narrative because we're all
part of groups in different ways,
but the collectivist narrative that I
regard as politically correct as a
pastiche of a strange pastiche of
postmodernism and neo Marxism in its
fundamental claim is that no,
you're not essentially an individual.
You're essentially a member of a group
and that group might be your ethnicity
and it might be your sex and it might be
a race and it might be any of the
endless numbers of other potential
groups that you belong to because you
belong to many of them and that you
should be essentially categorized along
with those who are like on that
dimension in that group.
That's proposition number one.
Proposition number two is that the
proper way to view the world is as a
battleground between groups of different
power.
So you define the groups first and then
you assume that you,
you,
you viewed the individual from the group
context.
You viewed the battle between groups
from the group context and you view
history itself as a consequence of
nothing but the power maneuvers between
different groups that eliminates any
consideration of the individual and at a
very fundamental level and also any
idea,
for example,
of free speech because if you're
collectivist at heart in this manner,
there is no such thing as free speech.
It isn't that it's debated by those on
the radical left and let's say the rest
of us so to speak.
It's that in that formulation there's no
such thing as free speech because for an
individualist free speech is how you
make sense of the world and reorganize
society in a proper manner,
but for the radical left type
collectivist that's associated with this
viewpoint of political correctness,
when you speak,
all you're doing is playing a power game
on behalf of your group and there's
nothing else that you can do because
that's all there is and not only is that
all there is in terms of who you are as
an individual now and how society should
be viewed.
It's also the fundamental narrative of
history.
For example,
it's widely assumed in our universities
now that the best way to conceptualize
Western civilization is as an oppressive
male dominated patriarchy and that the
best way to construe relationships
between men and women across the
centuries is one of oppression of women
by men as like,
well,
look,
no hierarchy is without it's tyranny.
That's a.
that's an axiomatic truth.
People have recognized that literally
for thousands of years and hierarchies
do tend towards tyranny and they tend
towards the use of patient by people
with power,
but that only happens when they become
corrupt and we have mechanisms in our
society to stop hierarchies from
becoming intolerable,
be corrupt,
and they actually work pretty well and
so and so.
I would also.
I would also point this out,
you know,
don't be thinking that this is a debate
about whether empathy is useful or not
or that the people on the con side of
the argument are not empathetic.
I know perfectly well as sure Mr Frye
does that.
Hierarchies tend to produce situations
where people stack up at the bottom and
that the dispossessed and hierarchies
need a political voice,
which is the proper voice of the left by
the way,
and the necessary voice of the left,
but that is not the same as proclaiming
that the right level of analysis for our
grand unifying narrative is that all of
us are fundamentally to be identified by
the groups that we belong to and to
construe the entire world as the
battleground between different forms of
tyranny in consequence of that group
affiliation and to the degree that we
play out that narrative that won't be
progress.
Believe me,
and we certainly haven't seen that
progress in the universities.
We've seen situations like what at
Wilfrid laurier university.
Instead we won't see progress.
What will return to is exactly the same
kind of tribalism to characterize the
lamp.
Thank you.